[Music]
a young girl shocks the judges on
america's got talent with her stunning
vocals
this year
i mean it is off the hook it's not
normal but we aren't the only ones blown
away by 11 year old maddie taylor baez
i'm not kidding in all the years we've
ever done this this has never actually
happened before agt producers through
judges simon cowell howie mandel sophia
vergara and heidi klum a curveball
during week 2 of season 17. maddie a
longtime fan of the show showed up to
the audition but the producers felt like
playing a little trick on the judges
[Music]
posing maddie as an audience member
during a commercial break who volunteers
to give it a shot it's always been my
dream to be on the show
and i'm finally here
sorry i'm just kind of freaking out
right now why not have you audition
yes
yes
wow
madison
i mean you don't need a track or
anything why don't you just do what you
just did
is that okay
and let's just say maddie wows with her
rendition of amazing grace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with powerhouse pipes like that it's no
surprise maddie gets a standing ovation
and she explains what she would do if
she won the one million dollar grand
prize her heartwarming answer is enough
to bring us to tears
i would help my dad with a cancer
research
he had stage four colon cancer
for the past nine years
so i would help him with that
the judges vote on whether matty will
move on to the next phase of competition
but howie mandel had other plans
[Applause]
there's not a dry eye in the room as
maddie gets howie's golden buzzer but no
one as proud as her dad who was there to
cheer on his little girl
she would sing to me at the hospital
throughout my surgeries while my chemo
treatments sing to me and helping me get
better and i'm doing very well
after maddie's impressive performance it
seems like agt has some tough
competition ahead et spoke with simon in
april and he said this season is
churning out some incredible talent last
year was good so you know but i that's
my that's my thing i like to get better
each year
[Music]
you